I want better for us.
I don't want hating your body
to be one of the most universal experiences for women.
This woman has lived a full life,
and yet one of her biggest fears is looking at her body,
seeing the number on the scale.
This is why I continuously talk about
unlearning your fatphobia.
Because you don't wanna wake up when you're 70
and hate your body.
Still hating your body.
Nobody deserves that.
This woman deserves to love herself and her body.
She got to grow old.
Do you understand what a privilege it is to grow old
and yet to get to an old age
and still feel like you're a stranger in your body,
still feeling uncomfortable when you look at yourself?
So many people will never
understand the peace that comes
with just being content in your own skin.
And that is literally all I ever want for any of us.
Because one day
you will wake up
and your life will have passed you by,
and you will still wake up unhappy with yourself
and unhappy with your body.
We are consistently being marketed to,
being told that we need to hate ourselves,
hate our bodies,
hate our size,
become small.
And unless you take active action,
unless you take a moment to look at your body
and just become comfortable to accept it,
unless you do that,
you will always be at odds with yourself.
You will always be fighting yourself.
Life Is difficult enough.
You at least deserve to feel peace
when you look at the mirror